we were just driving along this main
highway it's slightly higher than the
waters around it when we suddenly saw
all of these sack loads of grains and
trunks full of clothing so we stopped
and we just saw uh come with me i'll
show you we just saw people bringing
their stuff they're wading through the
water
um there's there's clothing
they've saved their bedding it's
completely drenched you can see the
water dripping from it they've even
brought these uh wooden beds
some people come on
up
what's up
guys so he's saying look at us
everything is absolutely soaked
everything is wrong
we're trying to save everything they're
saying that everything was drowned in
water
yeah i'm just telling him he can go and
save his stuff he doesn't have to stop
for us but you can see they are
salvaging precious little from all of
this i mean they've got their fans their
beds um
wow okay so
look at this
this is how they're bringing their stuff
across they've got some kind of rubber
tyre they're tying the beds upside down
to it and wading through the water i'm
going to step aside into the water a
little bit for you i mean little
children we've we've seen the elderly
the infirm
young old men women children they're
having to come through the water
um
sorry i just thought i'd better help
this little boy
over
abjay
tomorrow
oh
okay we won't um he started crying
i mean this is incredibly scary for
children it's really hard to explain
just how much water there is i mean
we're absolutely surrounded by it
now sir if you can show everyone
just ride across
everything and in fact
i don't know if you can see on screen
but
what my producer and cameraman were just
telling me is that look the water is
changing color there are two colors in
the water now that means there is now
water coming in as predicted from
further afield we were worried about the
um
water coming down from the north gushing
through as it's come down through the
various provinces we're right at the
bottom of pakistan glacier ice is
melting at the top flooding is happening
rivers are bursting their banks and
we're in the middle of a monsoon hard to
think of it now because it's so hot
so here we are there's a village or five
or six hundred people they're trying to
salvage what they can and we're trying
to show you exactly what people in
pakistan are experiencing as antonio
gutierrez the head of the un said that
this is a warning for the rest of the
world it's time to wake up to climate
change